hi there steve kaufman here steve of
link
ling cube
um today i want to talk about the
learning mindset or rather the growth
mindset when it comes to learning
and i'm going to follow this with
another video on the same subject in
french
um
what do i mean well people often come to
me and say
gee steve i wish i could learn languages
you're so lucky that you have a gift for
languages i'm lousy at languages i hear
that all the time
so lo and behold i get a
an email from my son
this morning and i don't know why he
sent it to me
but the title of this is an article by
salman khan salman khan is an american
who has created the can academy and i'm
going to put links here in the
description of this video
where he has provided these enormous the
fantastic resources for learning math
physics and other subjects
and he says why i'll never tell my son
he's smart now i never told my either of
my sons that they were smart
but he explains why he doesn't reward
his son
he doesn't say that he's smart he
praises him when he struggles to do
something that's difficult so that the
son
learns that the mind grows
if the mind struggles with something
that's a little difficult and overcomes
the difficulty and that's how people
become good learners and that's how the
mind grows and salmon can makes
reference in this article as i say i'm
going to put a link here
to a doctor carol dweck
who has done a lot of research on the
subject of what she calls the growth
mindset and she says there are two kinds
of learners there are the closed-minded
ones those who are persuaded they can't
do something and will only do things
that are easy for them and then there is
the growth mindset that enjoys a
challenge and those are the ones whose
minds grow
she has found that most people are here
adhere to one of two mindsets fixed or
growth fixed mindsets mistakenly believe
that people are either smart or not that
intelligence is fixed by genes people
with growth mindsets correctly believe
that capability and intelligence can be
grown through effort struggle and
failure and failure and i have always
felt this way with language people say
to me oh steve you're so lucky it must
be so easy for you i have yet to meet
someone who puts as much effort into
language learning as i do so my answer
is well first of all i'm on my 15th
language but i had to put a lot of
effort into my second language and third
language and so forth so why don't you
try
and then tell me if you aren't in fact
expanding your mind and slowly getting
better at it so i think this and i'm
going to put some additional links here
this idea of the growth mindset you can
google for growth mindset and i think it
has tremendous application for language
learning people always go on about how
audrey i got no talent and i always
respond to this talent thing by saying
well look at sweden
everybody there singapore all these
countries ethiopia where lots of people
are bi or trilingual
it's not because those people are
uniquely talented it's because for
whatever reason they have committed to
learning a language and therefore their
mind has grown and they've become more
capable at learning languages
now it all boils down to the whole
fundamental problem of motivation if
you're not motivated to learn well you
won't take on
the task
but if you are motivated i mean and and
if you can maintain that motivation you
will get better at it you'll get better
at the language and you will get better
at
the process of learning a language
for me of course
motivation is on the one hand the desire
to do something and then of course you
have to overcome the resistance and if
the resistance is too great
then a lot of people will give up and
that's normal and i think
there's this other flow theory where we
are most happy when we're taking on a
task that's difficult for us difficult
enough
but not too difficult so that we can
actually cope with it
but i think there's also a function
there of motivation so if we're very
motivate motivated we can deal with
something that's a little more difficult
if we're not motivated the slightest
difficulty is going to discourage us
that's why when i learn i avoid
tasks that destroy my interest
because much of my motivation is tied to
this sense of interest that i have so i
cannot study grammar rules because i
find it uninteresting
i can review grammar rules after i've
had a lot of exposure to the language
i'm now well into polish i've got
vocabulary i can understand lots i
haven't even looked at polish vocabulary
now you can say i have my ukrainian
russian that it helps but still i know
from experience that i'm more motivated
to get words in me to to deal with
interesting content uh and even if
initially the content isn't interesting
i'm motivated by the thought that within
a month or two i'll be able to read
articles in the newspaper struggling but
still be able to read articles in the
newspaper listen not really understand
and listen again and read the transcript
and all of that awaits me so that's
motivating for me
what's not motivating is when i used to
study languages and i would get you know
like a lot of teachers somehow think
that children's stories are good for
learners i'm not the slightest bit
interested in children's stories and the
vocabulary is not that interesting to me
the subject matter is sometimes in fact
more difficult than an article on
economics
i'm not again typically language
teachers and people who design textbooks
will have stories about native festivals
and
traditions of koreans or whoever and i'm
not that very interested in that so it's
very important to me as a learner that
i'm able to choose content that's of
interest to me that interest is a
motivator it enables me to overcome
difficulties in fact it makes it less
difficult so therefore i'm prepared to
take on the challenge and i'm prepared
to therefore i have a an open mindset a
growth mindset
but maybe i don't have a growth mindset
when it comes to learning
uh i don't know uh the piano or or
something that i'm not intrinsically
interested in so it does boil down to
the kind of motivation but if a person
is motivated to learn a language then to
say i am not talented i think is not
true
you have to create that talent in you
but the question is are you motivated
and can you find a path a learning path
that will maintain that motivation and
if you can
you can learn
if you have a growth mindset so for
those of you who are interested you can
look at the links that i'm going to put
in the description so there you have it
thanks for listening i hope you all have
a growth mindset
bye for now